hello and thank you for joining us today
i truly appreciate this opportunity to
work with the lab roots organization
and to support scientific advancement in
the cannabis industry
my name is kirsten blake and i'm the
vice president of emerald scientific
we are also the creators of the emerald
test ilc pt program
which is the first and only
internationally recognized
inter-laboratory comparison
proficiency testing program for the
cannabis
for cannabis analytics emerald
scientific is also the industry's
leading supplier for cannabis specific
scientific and laboratory supplies
calibration materials chemicals and
equipment
today i'm going to speak with you about
proficiency testing in the cannabis
industry
why this is important and the value
these programs can provide
some of you may not know what a
proficiency test is
so let's review the official definitions
essentially a proficiency test is any
activity undertaken by a laboratory to
provide evidence that they are
proficient to perform measurements
also according to iso iec 17043 2010
proficiency testing also known as a pt
is the evaluation of participant
performance against pre-established
criteria by
means of interlaboratory comparisons
so why are proficiency tests important
first and foremost pts are used to
verify that a laboratory's analytical
procedures
are effective and accurate and can be
used to confirm their methods and
standard operating procedures
these are also an important tool for
identifying areas for improvement
we can use the data from pt studies to
identify trends both within a facility
and the industry as a whole additionally
you can use
pts as a tool to evaluate your
individual analysts
capabilities you may want to consider
implementing this as part of your hiring
and training requirements
to avoid hiring individuals who may have
misrepresented their experience
and analytical capabilities this has
happened to more than one facility in
the cannabis
testing industry don't gamble with your
reputation
or your license to operate
so why is this important for the
cannabis industry proficiency tests are
an essential tool for ensuring consumer
safety
early on in this industry there were
what we call bad actors participating in
providing false quality reports
either by choice or they unknowingly
lacked the skills required to generate
accurate values for their analysis
this still persists as an issue in the
industry and while pts don't test for
ethics
they can at least test for labs
competency in providing accurate results
the only way to combat falsifying test
reports is through regular
and consistent enforcement of rules and
regulations
which can vary wildly from one state to
the next
additionally by participating in pts you
can help reduce the instance of product
liability
quality assurance testing ensures that a
product complies with state and local
regulations
which are generally focused on consumer
safety and knowing that these tests were
performed accurately will reduce the
instances
of product recalls and potential
lawsuits
for these reasons it is important to
note that proficiency tests are standard
in many other areas of analytics such as
food
pharmaceutical petrochemical and
environmental testing
by participating in proficiency tests
you can generate consumer confidence
in labs and the quality of work it is
not uncommon to hear other parts of the
cannabis industry bashing the quality
and consistency of lab results
i have years of data that indicate that
laboratories have consistently improved
their performance
in all areas of cannabis analysis as
they continue to take on more
challenging and difficult matrices
these tests do provide essential data
for regulating agencies to hopefully
consider
in their decision-making processes and
finally overall we see that laboratories
who participate
in proficiency tests regularly tend to
be more successful and exhibit improved
performance overall
so now that we've covered the basics you
might be wondering what types of
programs are available
there are a few state-run programs some
that offer
round robins and while not officially
pts these can provide useful data
if executed properly emerald scientific
has also worked with state agencies to
implement internal programs
to meet the unique challenges and
regulations within a specific market
there are also iso 17043 accredited pt
providers that do provide testing
material to the cannabis space
you can also work through distributors
like emerald scientific
who provide a diverse selection of
relevant pts for the industry
these can be in the form of quick turn
otherwise known as blind pts that are
available year round
along with internal or practice pts that
play an important role in day-to-day
internal qc operations or simply for
practice
we are starting to see government
agencies like nist
and standards organizations such as astm
begin to roll out early exploratory
tests
when it comes to inter-laboratory
comparison programs there are a few
limited options specifically focused on
hemp
and as noted earlier emerald scientific
offers the emerald test
ilc pt program which is which offers a
broad scope of tests and
analytes specifically chosen for the
relevancy
to the industry
i am going to provide a very broad
overview of the tests that are currently
available
and why we do these analysis
what is available well as you can see by
this extensive list you can really pick
your poison
starting with potency we now offer
multiple cannabinoid options in a
variety of matrices
accurate potency numbers are essential
for consumers to correctly dose for
their
desired outcome it is also important to
understand
the various cannabinoids in your product
as they can impact the
desired effect or treatment cannabinoid
content influences the price of the
product and as in the case of hemp it's
legality
as it is only legal at a total thc
content of 0.3
or less so accuracy is critical i want
everyone to understand that the analysis
of a homogenized
randomly selected sample will provide
more accurate average
of a batch cannabis plants do vary in
potency throughout the plant so those
pretty little crystallized buds at the
top of that plant are more potent
than the material that is lower and
deeper within the plant
so next let's talk about residual
solvents this test is primarily applied
to extracted products
sometimes manufacturers use
inappropriate chemicals or processes
for extracting cannabinoids that can
lead to unsafe residues remaining in the
product
additionally some manufacturers will use
cutting agents in their products
which is why we now offer pts for
tocopherol acetate
and propylene glycol as these can lead
to health hazards as exposed by the 2019
crisis and while terpenes are not a
required test in many regulated markets
consumers are starting to have a greater
interest and understanding of how these
aromatic
hydrocarbons that influence flavor and
aroma work in conjunction with the
cannabinoids
to deliver a preferred experience or
potential potential medicinal benefit
interestingly nevada is one of the few
states that lists dominant chirpings on
product labels
because the analytes we test for here
are so volatile
this is one of the more challenging pts
that we offer
so next let's talk about pesticides and
this is where my interest in industry
was first paid
i had naively assumed that most cannabis
was grown by eco-conscious growers out
in the hills
and of course they would do everything
organically but now that i understand
the value of cannabis as a commodity
and view it as an agricultural crop that
can be subject to a myriad of pests
mold mildews and other problems i could
see why a grower would turn to
pesticides and fungicides to protect
their investment
we've all heard cannabis called weed
because
it can grow like one right but this is
not always the case
when the wrong chemo bar is planted in
the wrong environment it will struggle
with pests
and disease similar to tomatoes that
have been bred for hot climates
and when they're planted on the coast
they struggle and just because you want
to grow the newest trend
super purple cotton candy lemon skunk
mind bender
you may not have the ideal environment
for it to thrive
next step let's talk about heavy metals
hemp which is cannabis
by the way has been used for
bioremediation for toxic sites for
decades
and is known to uptake toxic metals
quite efficiently
interestingly rpt data indicates that
most heavy metal pt failures
are with proper reporting of arsenic
mycotoxins here we're referring to
aflatoxins in oprah toxin
that can inhabit cannabis as well as
many other crops
aflatoxins are highly toxic secondary
metabolites
produced by the aspergillus fungi
as is ocratoxin and this can also be
produced by penicillium varicosum
both water activity and moisture are
important to measure as moisture can
lead to harmful microbiological growth
and on that note we offer a very broad
selection of microbiological tests as
well
some of the most recent pt editions that
we've brought about
are ph stability staphylococcus aureus
pseudomonas and foreign materials and
here we're looking for things like bugs
metal shavings rodent droppings and
other undesirable materials
so what is a matrix this refers to the
material in which we are looking for the
analytes of interest
first we started with solvents and this
is where it all started in 2014 with a
simple delta nine thc
test in an acetonitrile solution and
while some do criticize
in-solution pts these are metrologically
traceable
and can provide valuable information
about your analysis
from injection to detection so you will
be able to identify if you have a
problem with your analytical system
before you introduce more complex
actions like sample prep
other matrices do include hemp oil
olive oil mct oil hemp bud beverages
isolate gummies brownies chocolate
and most recently cosmetic cream which
should be an interesting analytical
challenge as this is comprised of both
hydrophobic and hydrophilic materials
as the industry continues to develop new
and interesting products
and there is no shortage of creativity
in this industry
we will continue to work with our
suppliers to bring relevant options to
the market
so next let's talk about the emerald
test
the testing program was an integral
component of emerald scientific's
initial business plan as a means to both
improve the science
and quality of analytics being performed
in the industry
and to give us greater credibility in
the scientific community
the test first launched in 2014 and was
the industry's first
nationwide cannabis interlaboratory
comparison proficiency testing program
when enrollment was first announced we
had a few labs that were really excited
and saw this as the right direction for
the industry
but after only a few initial sales
we heard only crickets so it's good
people
good sales people do we hopped on the
phone to talk to laboratory owners and
the directors and i want you all to
understand that the testing industry was
in a very different landscape back then
with little regulatory oversight and
only a few iso 17025 accredited
facilities
so we receive responses like this so you
want me to pay for a test
that's not required and it might show
that i don't know what i'm doing
i don't think so well regardless
we were able to gather enough
participants to launch
the first emerald test
so what is the emerald test it is an
inter-laboratory profession
it is an inter-laboratory comparison
proficiency testing program also known
as ilcpt
our goal is to help establish an
industry benchmark for cannabis and hemp
testing
while providing valuable feedback to
each participant's quality assurance
system
the test is offered by annually in the
spring and the fall
because it is an interlaboratory
comparison program you can see how your
results compare to others in the
industry
and all of the data is anonymous this
data is hugely beneficial for the
industry as we are able to identify
trends and areas for improvement
for example with the inaugural tests we
gathered a group of 16 participants
who were at that time primarily using
gas chromatography
for potency analysis our sample was
delta nine thc
in a solution of acetonitrile so this
was an appropriate means of analysis
but by the fall of 2016 we were
analyzing five cannabinoids
which included the assist acidic forms
of thc and cbd
and by that time all but one participant
was performing their analysis by hplc
this illustrates how rapidly the trends
in the industry
have changed in both analysis and the
equipment that is involved
so let's get back to the program if you
perform to an acceptable
standard you have the ability to earn
the emerald badge for that specific area
of analysis
the badge program was initiated to give
labs a brass ring to reach for
and to provide marketing support for
their bragging rights
unique to our program is that we consult
with an advisory panel
which is comprised of industry experts
and stakeholders representing a diverse
mix
from various areas of the industry to
provide relevant input and insight
it is important to note that some state
regulations do require testing labs to
participate
in annual and biannual pts
and this is also required if you are
seeking iso 17025 accreditation
which will require you to take a pt if
available
for each area of analysis for which you
are applying for the scope of your
accreditation
the emerald test is approved by the
primary accreditation groups
such as a nab a2la perry johnson labs
and rj lee group it is also important to
note that
currently all samples fall under the
rules for qualifying as dea exempt
materials
which allows us to ship these samples
nationwide and internationally with few
exceptions
pass fail criteria is determined by the
iso 17043 pt manufacturers
and while some tests are graded by
standard mean others are graded by known
value
which is metrologically traceable this
is also determined by the iso 17043
pt manufacturer and can change as more
historical performance data is gathered
unlike other areas of analytics
currently
at the time of this presentation field
of proficiency
tables known as fopt tables which
provides specific guidance for
establishing passing criteria
and test design do not exist for the
cannabis industry
by leveraging the input of our advisory
panel our customers
and ever changing regulations we
continually advocate
for new and approved tests that are
relevant to the needs of the industry
this graph recently generated by new
frontiers data
illustrates the expansion of the emerald
test ilcpt program since 2014
and while i recognize that this slide
may be difficult to read
what is important to know is that over
time we have continued to add new tests
and matrices
to address the industry's analytical
needs
all right so let's get to the data
already how it's delivered and what does
it mean
initially you will receive an individual
performance report
for each test in which you have
participated this is generally what your
auditors will review
after we've completed a statistical
analysis of the testing round you will
receive a full report
with a data summary in this example for
pesticides
and this is from the spring of 2000 2020
and this is just a little subsection of
the pesticides here
a statistical summary was provided and
here you can see that more challenging
analytes such as abamectin which is
circled in red
will have a higher standard deviation
than those analytes easier to
identify such as boscolin which is
circled in green
z-score data was also provided which
easily identifies standard deviation
results
by color
also provided resize score graphs and
gaussian
normal distribution plots the way data
is visualized
and tracking this data historically can
provide insights into the challenges
and improvements both in performance and
analytics
and the design of a test
so who should participate in proficiency
testing as i already noted
any lab seeking iso 17025 accreditation
and obviously if you are a lab required
by state regulations to do so
but also in-house quality control and r
d lab should participate to ensure that
your analytics are in alignment with the
industry
we are also seeing an increase in
equipment providers participating to
ensure that the equipment and methods
they are providing to the industry
are capable of providing the analytics
required
so let's touch upon some brief
highlights from the most recent fall
2020 round of the emerald test ilc pt
program it is worth noting that the labs
were all very responsive during the test
period
even though there was a global pandemic
potency performance is solid
but in all cannabinoid tests cbn cbd and
cba had
significantly higher standard deviations
than other potency
analytes which indicates that these are
more challenging
to accurately quantify terpene analysis
continues to be the most challenging
test with
beta-caryophyllene providing or proving
to be the most difficult analyte
in some microbio biological tests we
increase the number of samples in the
test and the pass rate remained the same
but with aspergillus molds the panel
increased from three samples to ten and
the pass rate increased by five percent
which was unexpected
with the mycotoxins test the pass rate
was 2 percent better than historic
performance
and for pesticides the average recovery
of the certified value improved from 88
percent to 96 percent
in reviewing participation we had a
total of 123 different cannabis and or
hemp
testing facilities enrolled for the fall
and will test
representing 30 states and 8 foreign
countries
this is the 13th consecutive round that
the number of participants has increased
and while some labs are unable to submit
results it is noteworthy
that 610 pts were entered for review
which culminated in 511 emerald test
badges being awarded
it was also noted that this round
continued a significant trend in the
diversity of enterprises participating
in the emerald test
the program is now being utilized by
regulatory bodies
equipment manufacturers method
development entities
cultivators extraction businesses and
consumable product creators
fall 2020 results indicate that matrix
does influence accuracy as represented
in this bar graph
illustrating the potency results for
both hemp bud
and hemp oil potency results have shown
consistent improvement over time
with an average pass rate of 89 percent
over the history of the test
additionally labs have demonstrated
exceptional results across other
matrices
including gummies beverages and hard
candy
the combined pass rate was 97 percent
the graph here illustrates that gummies
present a greater analytical challenge
for potency analysis than beverage or
hard candy
we just completed enrollment for our
spring 2021 round
so here's the summary of the enrollment
we had 139 individual labs enroll
representing 12 countries for a total of
760
tests so the enroll is comprised of
cannabis testing labs
hemp testing labs instrument instrument
manufacturers
government labs and cannabis product
manufacturers
so let's talk about some key insights
and what might be coming next
according to new frontiers data growth
in the cannabis sales
is expected to more than double in the
next four years
recent legalization activities in
several states
the influence those will have on the
surrounding states combined with the
increased
acceptance of the need for regulatory
oversight
and testing requirements positions the
lab testing market for exponential
growth within the next few years
in this highly competitive market it
will be more critical than ever
for labs to differentiate from one
another through accreditation and proof
of analytical capability
we are seeing a notable increase in
manufacturers and cultivators embracing
and investing
in in-house testing capabilities and we
expect to see this trend continue as we
move toward
improved processes such as good
manufacturing
practices otherwise known as gmp of
which testing is an important component
this will influence domestic and
international trade and thus requiring a
greater demand for quality analytics
looking to the future cbd is a
hot topic right now and pun intended the
highly restrictive 0.3 percent threshold
for thc content in hump derived products
reinforces urgency for precise
quantification capabilities
it is still uncertain how and to what
extent this market segment will be
effectively regulated as a reply as it
applies to consumer safety
and next i'll talk briefly about delta
eight this is a rising player in the cbd
hunt market
in this presentation i'm hesitant to
navigate the legal framework of delta
eight
similar to a stormy day it appears to be
dark and gray
but there is much controversy
surrounding the popular cannabinoid
typically derived from hemp-based cbd
what i can address is that there is an
issue in the testing industry
where some labs are unable to accurately
differentiate between delta 8 and delta
9 in their analysis
we are working with our suppliers to
help address this problem by delivering
a delta 8 delta 9 proficiency test
before the end of the month so so what
are the challenges we continue to face
that pertain to proficiency tests first
cannabinoid tests must meet
qualification for dea exempt materials
this means that they must be below one
milligram per mill in thc concentration
we are also unable to ship samples in a
solid matrix above
0.3 thc across state lines
and this is unlikely to change until we
see some form of federal legalization
the exception to this may be if you have
a dea license to handle schedule 1 drugs
the vast variability across state
regulations makes it difficult to create
tests that are relevant for all markets
also as noted earlier we are a young
industry and still lack enough
historical data to
to determine passing criteria is
typically referenced by fopt
fopt tables and finally we continue to
work toward
customer education and as to the value
of proficiency testing programs and what
they provide to the industry
participation in these in these programs
goes well beyond
just a marketing opportunity
participation contributes to the overall
advancement of cannabis science
like to acknowledge my references
and thank you i truly appreciate your
attention and interest
and a huge thank you to the lab roots
organization for allowing me to
participate today
and for all they do to support the
cannabis analytical space